first up he is the former fbi deputy
assistant director
of counterintelligence mile job and
author of the new book
compromise counterintelligence and the
threat of donald j
trump peter strzok peter strzok thank
you so much
okay peter are you there on my zoom
i am bill it's great to be here great to
have you thank you
let's uh hope the zoom holds up
sometimes it doesn't the first thing i
want to ask you is
you know you're a g-man your whole life
and they're known to be apolitical
does it amuse you does it infuriate you
what does it do to you
that it used to be only a few years ago
that it was the
the liberals who were suspicious of law
enforcement and now that's completely
switched
you're the good guy with the liberals
and it's the republicans
who who are uh who think you're the bad
guy what does that do to you
no it's crazy and it's hard to imagine
how fast that happened
and it makes you wonder how long it's
going to last and some of that you can
expand from that you know the people
cozying up with the russians are not
the pinko communist liberals anymore
you've got it turned upside down so
the question is in this topsy-turvy
world how long is it going to take back
to revert
and whether or not that happens at all
or in some bizarre new world of
domestic political alliances and beliefs
right well listen um obviously trump
put you in a completely impossible
position yeah when i say you you guys in
the fbi you
certainly were high up there at the time
because he he was outrageous in his
behavior he was saying things publicly
like russia if you're listening
you know it was ridiculous you had to
look into him
that's my view that you know this
crossfire hurricane which was the
looking into whether trump was a
mentoring you had to do it but it's
interesting that
once it was done you know we have to be
open-minded here
it seems to me your view was that there
was not
something that happened there you said
in a private text so we know it was real
you said my gut sense and concern
is that there's no big there there uh
you said we have not seen the new york
times had a big story
in 2017 right after trump was
inaugurated and trump campaign aides
had reported contacts with rep russian
intelligence was the headline
and you said we have not seen evidence
of any of that
he said we are unaware of any trump
advisers engaging in conversations with
russian intelligence
officials that confuses me uh the don jr
i can understand uh the the manafort we
found out was
was giving polling data to this
constantine kalimko who has been called
a russian agent
why did you say there was no there there
um well so you have to read that last
document like a legal document we were
trying to figure out when that new york
times article came out who the hell was
talking to the times
because they got a lot of things wrong
but some of the things were accurate and
so we were trying to figure out okay who
were those sources
and when you see when i say no
intelligence officers
you got to think about that like a
counterintelligence person you know i
spent 20 years chasing spies and
recruiting people
and when i say that i'm talking about
like a full-fledged foreign intelligence
officer not
somebody who might be working with them
and that's the kind of person we saw
all over the trump campaign we had him
in contact with a foreign policy advisor
we had him in contact with the incoming
attorney general we had him in contact
with the incoming national security
adviser
and person after person after person in
the trump campaign
had these undisclosed contacts with the
russians that they
started and continue not telling the
truth about
so when i sit there and look at it the
worst thing could be it's some big
conspiracy
kind of run from the top by the
president but it doesn't have to be that
to be really bad
it's kind of like if you walk outside
and the entire block has every car has
its window knocked out
you could say well you know we don't
think one person did this well every
window is still knocked out
it's still bad and so when i looked at
that when i made that comment
i was simply saying i don't think trump
is sitting like a mastermind
on top of all these contacts controlling
and coordinating what's going on
what i thought was there a bunch of
grifters
opportunists people trying to make money
all sort of individually pursuing their
agendas in a way that made them
vulnerable to the russian intelligence
i think you're right he's definitely not
a mastermind
oh really no honestly
i mean
finally it sounds like a full crowd
no i mean but i i constantly think
people give him too much credit for that
and i think you're right
it wasn't like that i think it's just
the way you described it in fact
uh dan coats who was the director of
national intelligence for a while he
said
he thinks putin has something on trump
well that may be true
but i think what he has on trump is the
knowledge that trump is
a giant narcissist or at least that's
what i have on trump
i i don't think you need to have
something on trump i learned this a
couple of weeks ago when
q anon you know the total nut cases who
think that the world is run by this
secret cabal
of of pizza eating pedophiles
who eat babies you know i mean they're
really out there and and trump
when they always asked about him yeah i
think they're good people and i take
their support
whoever says they like him he likes them
if it's white supremist and they say
they like him he likes them if it's
vladimir putin and he says
i think trump is brilliant trump is like
i love this guy
i don't think it's much more complicated
than that right it's about the
narcissism
i think that's one thing look if you're
if you're trying to deal with somebody
that might be enough but put yourself in
the shoes of
the svr or any russian intelligence
service just because something works
you're not going to stop with that
so sure putin he's got a team of
psychologists who have looked at trump
they probably know him better than most
americans do and they know how to push
his buttons and play him
but that's not going to stop them from
finding other things to hold his
leverage over
some of that's coming out in the public
like we had through the mueller report
the example of trump is on the campaign
trail in 2016.
and he tells a crowd i think down in
north carolina i have no financial
dealings
in russia whatsoever none at the exact
same instant
michael cohen and others are trying to
get a deal at trump tower in moscow
well trump knows he just didn't tell the
truth he know he lied
putin knows he lied and so to maintain
that because if putin turns around and
says hey look i'm going to tell the
truth
and your every one of your campaign or
the people at that rally are going to
know you lied
that gives them leverage so if you're an
intelligence service you don't stop just
because you have one avenue in you keep
looking for all these different ways to
impact somebody's behavior
you